[Music]
free
yo i see tragic
yeah look
i'm so underrated if my mum debated then
the world would be lost to this
greatness still but stainless
i could honestly go head-to-head of any
rappers on your playlist told you i'd
make it
that's what happens when your mind is
creative destined to make things there's
a box where your brain is but i think
outside a man never basic i'm from a
place where there's no support
stood by myself then i chose to walk
moves in silence never chose to talk i
had friends who were fools as oops
i see separation like a moses will try
having moon hearts with the coldest
fools they should actually call me the
fire of london i burn bridges with no
removes it's mad they don't believe till
they see it
so man had to be see it never mean i'm
not a mug what tears never mean i'm not
a bug they're fleeing i put that key in
got my foot in the door so i change with
the moves they're seeing don't hate on
you if she's preempt
one lung is a rat i keep breathing yeah
i took the commercial route but the
rumors you heard the truth
if it's a battle then i'm turning rude
keep up with the pen game like endgame
when i snap you lose not nhs
i won't clap for you my guys might let
it clap for you rappers claim to the
best that i showed in the best let me
lighten the mood can i rap for you
in my end they didn't want to put me in
top 10 if that's spitting then i got
phlegm they said ash you don't release
enough tracks now it's mad ironic how i
shocked them
i'll top them if it gets out of hand
then i'll drop them if it gets out of
hand and i've got men and i don't rate
your class like offset stop that you
want to face time and it's not pen two
call my image no caption
baby face but their brain waves more
than a fraction their words don't match
their actions they want war but they've
got more flaws in a match and 10 out of
10's call me handsome
wanna hold me for ransom man it's just
too many but i can't wipe and you need a
certain girl never random
these rappers are tiring fake guys
you're admiring if it's levels in a team
that you know i'll hire him sir i don't
know mike i'm firing loose cannon when i
write i'm firing got too much pride
where you're lying king got flows that
will hype your team and i make a crowd
jump like it's frightening
working 90 so i know what a rap is
offset i beat so i know what a whack is
take shots when i'm rapping so you best
have booze if you're making a rack it
came in too cold now they're wearing a
jacket
oh yeah and a jacket that's a reload one
of the hardest and he knows no spam will
you back it
no with my team called his ice cream but
i'm loved to the tinker cooley waffy
jose mccree
show you my dream and i look off your
wave like kobe 19 chose the right scene
still do grime the flows are quite clean
never been high i know they like green
never been the right decision to try me
to roll like ig when you're about to
flow
everybody wants to know when you're
trying to grow
everybody wants to know when you're
doing shows
everybody wants to know but there was no
support
so tell them haters no no no
you